[Music]
right now for more reaction on tonight's
big breaking news that the Inspector
General horowitz has submitted his
Pfizer report for classification review
to the DOJ Fox News contributor former
Republican congressman trey Gowdy you
first said and I'll get to this in a
second that the idea that now mccabe
they passed on any special treatment but
it was a while ago that report
identified the Inspector General report
identified him as a liar and a leaker
and you said it's a celebration of our
justice system now we had the second
minor report that was Comey lacking
candor but that didn't result in well it
did result in a referral but it doesn't
seem like they're moving forward why is
this taking so long and we'll get to
FISA neck because I have some concerns
about what the outcome will be you know
Sean there was a trial in DC what last
week and former White House Counsel Greg
Craig was found not guilty and what was
a really quick jury verdict these are
tough cases it is harder than it might
appear to convince 12 people of anything
I used to have to do it for a living
it's tough so you've got to dot every I
and cross every T and quite candidly it
is more difficult if it's a high-profile
defendant so if they go forward with
McCabe you can rest assured that's going
to be a tough trial we don't want the
United States government going to trial
and losing on a regular basis they lost
the Greg Craig that's not good so if
you're going to go to trial you need to
win you never lost the case as a
prosecutor that's why you know you're so
good at what you do here's my question
so we now know I can give you as the
relates to FISA and the FISA inspector
general report we I know of three
separate times including by the way the
UK memo warning warning about steals
credibility but we know three separate
instances before the first FISA
application was signed the bulk of
information we now know was the
unverified dirty Russian dossier likely
Russian disinformation according to the
New York Times from the get-go but they
were warned about steals credit bill
before they sign the first FISA they
were warmed by Bruce or the UK was
warning about his credibility that steel
had an agenda
it wasn't verified and Hillary paid for
it now they used it anyway now we know
it's unverifiable because steel never
stood by his own dossier and under oath
said I have no idea of any of its true
now to me that seems like premeditated
fraud on a FISA Court and when you
couple that with Andrew McCabe the
deputy at-bat director saying well no
dossier no FISA warrant that makes me
think they didn't care about what they
were presenting to the court and that
was a fraud and they knew it was a fraud
but they said it was verified and it
wasn't let's assume for the sake of
argument that everything you said was
true let's just assume that you still
have to find a criminal statute if your
objective is indictment which is why I'm
really clear every time y'all are good
enough to have me on we cannot live in a
society where indictment is the only
thing that carries with it any stigma I
mean most of the names involved with the
FISA approval process in 2016 if he's
been fired or they've been publicly
called a task keep in mind Jim Comey
twice now the Inspector General had said
you did not meet our expectations you
failed to follow policy you violated
your employment agreement all of that
has to be significant look I used to
make representations in front of a court
and I tried really hard to be honest and
fair about it but let's assume then I
didn't tell the court something the
remedy for me is not indictment the
remedy is I may lose my law license
remedy this way that may hold me in
contempt
here's the thing if I am warned that
something that I'm about to present in
court is false and at the top of an
application I'm making to the court it
says it's verified and I test that I
sign it say that it's verified but I was
warned that it isn't and I don't do the
job of verifying it because it's
unverifiable we know now when the FBI
finally got into you know their
spreadsheet they discovered 90 plus
percent of not all of the dirty dossier
was untrue so that was later though so
if I'm if I know rich
I know it's not verified and I present
it as verified and it's unverifiable
that would seem like Sean Hannity went
to the court and committed a fraud on
the court consciously for the purpose of
achieving a political agenda why do I
think trey Gowdy is great an attorney as
you are never lost the case of the
prosecutor that I go to jail well it
depends if you're a lawyer you would
lose your law license and the court can
hold you in contempt remember Devon and
I wrote the law before a judge
we talked about lying before a judge
you'll be hella will be held in contempt
of court absolutely and you can go to
jail for that I don't know that lawyers
who make facts will represent eight
misrepresentations in front of judges
wind up getting indicted you're going to
get punished you're gonna be held in
contempt you may get sent to prison and
look I'm not minimizing any of what
they've done I'm saying we've got angle
test the right punishment to the right
offense so you're denying by signing
that an American citizen their
constitutional rights
you're you're literally using that lie
to spy on a presidential candidate
campaign and then transition aha we've
identified a statute using the color of
government official it could be a 1983
action and that's all I'm saying is
we've got to match up the conduct with a
specific code violation what you see
right now
regularly over three violation now we're
getting somewhere
I'll send you Greg Garrett's list but we
he's identified a whole variety crimes
perpetrating a fraud on the Comoros or
did to me sent it to bill bar I mean
okay well nobody right now I don't know
bill bar so I bet I'd be glad to not
only I think the bars probably are very
aware of what the statutes applicable
statutes would be so trey Gowdy good to
see you